Twilight is the boundary between day and
night.Things with a copy
hide themselves in the darkness.Things that do not exist are hidden
in the
darkness.Everything in
Kure's day is dyed by him, making it vague.The
shadow of the good is deeper and thicker.  That's what
I am, those who are in the middle are
easy to cross the boundary
People in the past said that time was when they met monsters
Yuki
You're Imai, when the demon is
coming Yeah
yeah yeah tan  Seriously,
I met a timid guy, I found it, Magatsugami, Bishabon, a
suicide note,
ah, the
strongest star I know,
vinegar miso,
so you're friends?
I'm the one who
's being
targeted.
Let's go inside 6
Design
[Applause]
There was a brain
Bishamon is that Bishamonten